that shoemaker on the hill for the twins
today getting the start
and to the opposite field and inside the
line
whit is digging for second
and he is in there with a game opening
double andrews having a good year after
a difficult start in april
look up in the zone and it was up in the
zone my goodness have you seen this game
already no i haven't
it's it's been intended it's his stroke
it's hit the fact that he can wait on
baseballs coming towards him
display a really good arm here's a
little pop-up and polanco back thank
goodness he's busting bats all over the
place and perez quickly retired for out
number two again a long hold and strike
three
a couple of hits off the end of the bat
producing the first run of the game
kansas city breaks out on top one
nothing
and brad keller when he's right is a
tough guy to elevate
there's a base hit to center and there
goes the ducks
[Applause]
a base hit for kirill off with donaldson
going to second two aboard now for
nelson cruz
and now a walk to fill the bases for
cenote
[Music]
got him and now sono only has himself to
blame he chased one down and out of the
strike zone
and a base of loaded walk ties the game
and larnick gets credit for the run
batted in
third walk of the inning you've talked
about the maturity that larnic has shown
looks like he's totally comfortable with
what his approach is and what he's
trying to do
fastball and that strikes him out so
it wasn't pretty but keller holds the
twins to one despite giving up a hit and
three walks
one and two from shoemaker
and a strikeout for the first out of the
second good change up and a great spot
see that's split finger grip ball go
looks like a fastball goes straight down
got him putting it in some good spots
picked up three strikeouts and has just
finished a one two three second inning
ben rorfett will lead things off got a
run to tie it left the bases full in the
first and now rourke lifts it high and
deep left center field headed to the
bullpen and gone
ben rorfett jumping on the first pitch
and hitting his first home run that's an
impressive swing by that young man right
there
[Applause]
and a called third strike on a fastball
that's keller's third
hit to an open spot of the infield
and carol off will get an infield hit
with the ship it was monday scampering
over
to pick the ball up keep the ball from
getting into the outfield if it had
gotten by him pretty good chance simmons
would have scored
and cruz
hits it into right field he put his head
down immediately and olivares will make
the play too in the inning ben rortbett
hits his first big league home run and
gives the twins a 2-1 lead
and the pitch and ceno is fooled again
on the slider that's keller's fourth and
his second against cino
out over the plate
lifted to center field dyson is there
and keller has his first two three
inning at the end of three in
minneapolis the twins lead 2-1
one and two and strike three shoemaker
strikes out ben and teddy to start the
fourth inning 40 pitches 30 strikes for
shoemaker 1-2
and how about matt shoemaker another
1-2-3 inning he sent down 12 men in a
row
and the 2-2 and a swing and a miss
on a pitch down and rorbed strikes out
that's five of them now for brad keller
on the ground to santana and that's the
inning so three up three down again and
now it's nine of ten set down by keller
there's a base hit into left field and
number one for olivares this year he's
finding a hole there gutierrez with a
runner at first base that's out over the
plate and that's hit into center field
olivares makes the turn and then almost
as an afterthought heads for third but
he will beat the throw first and third
for k.c great chance to tie or take the
lead and here the batter is hunter
dozier
so a trade-off here
safe
twins will take outs the royals will
take the run we're tied at two and
minnesota
is unable to turn the double play
he gets it by donaldson and into left
field the royals have three hits in the
inning
and two on with one out dyson is one for
two so casey has him on first and second
only one out with wood merrifield coming
up
lined into left field and down in front
of larnick
coming around third is dozier
as the ball gets away from the minnesota
infield and whitmerfield drives in his
fourth run of the series
and the royals are out in front for a
second time today
and santana takes inside to load the
bases
shoemaker was on a roll 11 straight then
a succession of singles
and now a walk they're loaded up and the
royals have a lead with a chance to
break it open field bar will pitch next
in the air to center field ref snyder is
back and he's got it
two runners will tag the royals lead 4-2
dyson scores merrifield goes to third
and ben and tendy drives in his second
he's facing salvador perez and on his
sheet that he just put back in his
pocket after he saw that
he said highly flammable be careful
there you go
[Applause]
and he just lays him a cookie in there
it is a four run fifth inning and the
royals lead five two look at that that a
nice easy swing
you see that donaldson count of one ball
two strikes
hit the right field fairly well long run
he's not going to get it
it will hit off the padding of the wall
and donaldson
with a stand-up double
[Applause]
[Music]
and a basement to the opposite field for
kiralov
donaldson will be held at third so the
twins taking a page from the royals book
with the twins filling the bases second
time for cino
grounded to third
and it'll be a double play no run batted
in for ceno the twins get one but
keller a ground ball pitcher got a big
one when he needed it donaldson scoring
from third it's five to three
and a called third strike and my
goodness how many times have we said it
could have been a lot worse it applies
in this inning
slow breaking ball missed and polanco
will take that walk
and checked his swing and he took ball
forward that's a heck of a walk taken by
the rookie yes it is so
zimmer departs with two on one out and
nelson cruz is coming up against scott
barlow
got him
the slider down and away two down
and cenote strikes out and barlow comes
back from three and one
that one poke the left center field
hanging in the air red snyder lays out
again makes a nice diving catch
one more time in the gap never played
center field before huh gets a good jump
on it
[Applause]
he tells
he tells larnock he's got it even though
it's going to be a dive for him to
be that sure
so no chasing this
[Music]
and making the catch a one two three
eight for cola made
wounds will try to build another threat
in the bottom of the eighth
barlow
struck out the two men he faced in the
seventh and now that one hits larnick
and
this time it didn't come anywhere near
the bat
and the slider is ball four so a hit
batter and a walk
line and santana did that go off of his
bare hand either way
he goes to the bag and
the twins strand two more
now dozier for the royals
and there's a drive to deep left field
into the corner and off the second deck
so there's his second contribution
hunter dozier gives the royals
more breathing room it is 6-3 in the
ninth inning
on the ground monday
over to santana and the royals take two
out of three from the minnesota twins
and win a series in minnesota for the
first time since 2017 so that's reason
to celebrate